[music]
>> Point number five, to experience the
management and running of the IRF being
the world's best Islamic organization.
I'm not aware
whether IRF is the best or not,
but may Allah accept the efforts of IRF.
And inshallah,
during this course of the training,
in the next
3 4 weeks, inshallah, we'll be
completing 25 years, inshallah.
On the 16th of February, 1991,
the IRF was inaugurated.
And inshallah, in the next few weeks,
we'll be completing 25 years.
May Allah accept the efforts.
If Allah accepts the efforts, khalas.
We don't need anything more than that.
You want me to work in the akhirah,
inshallah. May Allah accept it.
Point number six, to learn from good
experiences of others to be able to
replicate them and learn from the
mistakes or experience of others
and not to repeat them.
And that's good.
That
the average man learns from his own
mistakes.
The intelligent man learns from other
people's mistakes.
For me, you inshallah
be able to be more effective.
And the seventh expectation is to
develop better presentation skills,
especially on stage and on TV programs.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala fulfill
all your good and correct expectations.
Amen.
The next
on my list is Koichiro Sugimoto.
And I hope I'm pronouncing it correctly.
Alhamdulillah.
To acquire proper techniques and
strategies along with basic knowledge of
Islam and other religions for an actual
impact in dawah.
Number two, to develop personal skills
in the area of doing substantial and
effective Dawah.
Inshallah.
Point number three, to master commonly
asked questions on Islam by non-Muslims.
Inshallah.
Point number four, to understand Dawah
methodology of the prophet.
That's a very important point.
Point number five, to acquire effective
memorization skills.
Expectation number six,
to understand training methods of Dawah
training.
So that I become a trainer, Inshallah.
And number seven, to understand how to
use technology
for effective Dawah.
This itself, as I mentioned, is a
specialization. We'll be touching on
some aspects
of technology, mainly satellite media,
which I believe today is number one.
Number two is social media. We'll be
touching on that. And on other aspects
also, Inshallah.
May Allah make it possible for you to
achieve all the seven expectations.
Brother Omar Yusuf,
number one, know about effective Dawah
techniques.
>> [snorts]
>> May Allah make you implement it.
It's more important than knowing.
May Allah make you implement effective
Dawah techniques.
Number two, exposure to comparative
religion and Dawah to those of this
kind. This kind means?
Uh of this kind means people of other
religions.
People of comparative religions, in
fact. It should not be people of
comparative religion. It should be
people of other religions. That's
correct.
Because every one of other religion is
not a comparative. Comparative religion
means a person who compares religions.
So every non-Muslim does not compare
religions.
That's what it meant, but it should mean
people of other religions, Inshallah.
Point number three, with Dawah training
program will get in touch with one
prominent Islamic firm
to enhance my future endeavors. You're
talking about IRF. Yes.
Number four, learn about IRF and Peace
TV's organizational administrative
structure
in building a well-off
Islamic organization.
What do you mean by well-off?
Uh professionalism and uh how they
manage things, administration and
everything. Well-off means financially.
Not financially.
>> Financially.
So, you'd like to know the
professionalism of IRF.
Inshallah, may Allah make it possible.
Though, we'll not be going to details of
that. We have given one day
for the management skills. We have given
one day
for Dawah through satellite, where we'll
be touching on
some aspects of Peace TV, some aspects
of IRF also, inshallah.
Experience mingling with people of many
different cultures.
This expectation can be done
even with other ways. You can be a
tourist also and experience that. Fine,
you will mix with people, inshallah.
But, that can be done even without
attending the course, correct?
I would prefer your expectation should
be such
which is only available here.
Correct?
Right or wrong?
That is called age of specialization.
If you would have come here because I
want to see Bombay, yes, you can.
You can come here and see Bombay.
It's an expectation which will be
fulfilled,
but nothing unique,
nothing great.
Meeting other people,
yes, you can say want to meet dais
of different parts of the world,
alhamdulillah. It's an opportunity,
though it may not be a very
high priority, but it is little unique.
But, saying that
experiencing mingling with people of
many different cultures, that can be
done in Sri Lanka. Many tourists are
coming. I've been to Sri Lanka many
times, masha Allah. And there are so
many foreigners.
You'll be able to get that here, but
nothing unique.
I wouldn't conduct a Dawah training
program to let people mix of different
kind. I can do it even without me that I
can organize and call people.
Here it is more of Dawah. Number six,
increase use of Quran for myself.
Inshallah. Number seven, get well into
position to become a full-time Dahi.
Inshallah.
We pray that
all the correct expectations that you
have
from these seven get fulfilled,
Inshallah. Amen.
Next on my list is brother Ibrahim
Kutty.
Number one, to learn my strengths and
weaknesses in not only Dawah, but in my
personal Islamic practices.
Inshallah.
There are many people who after doing
the Dawah training program have said
that not only have I
excelled in Dawah,
I've even started excelling in my
business.
I said, "Why?" Because I use that same
technique for my business.
I've become better in my profession. How
come? I'm performing better.
I'm a better engineer. How come? I use
the same principles
for my profession.
And that is an art.
That Inshallah when we meet people
who are experienced in the field, we
gain from them. And I normally have a
policy.
I spend my time
if one of the two are fulfilled.
Either I'm benefiting someone
or he's benefiting me.
If I don't benefit someone and neither
is he benefiting me, I don't waste my
time.
My time is very precious.
Either I'm benefiting someone or
I'm being benefited. Many a time I go
for both.
I do Dawah training program,
whether benefits you or not is
secondary, it will Inshallah benefit me.
Every training program I conduct,
it improves my own skills
and gets me closer to Allah. It's a
reminder for me.
My connection with Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala
on the hotline
Masha'Allah increases. Hotline, don't
get me wrong. Everyone has a hotline.
It's open secret.
Allah says in the Quran is closer to you
than your jugular vein.
Correct?
But
if you
take advantage of that closeness of
Allah, will you benefit or what's the
use?
You have the hotline, but you forgot the
number of the hotline. What is the use?
The hotline is I'm only reminding you
the number.
And what's the number?
What's the number?
What is the number, Farik?
Huh?
What is the number of hotline?
Uh 16125.
Okay, but what's the number?
Yes, brother.
What is the hotline number? It's the
same.
2443 24434
Hopefully, yes.
What is the number of the hotline?
Put your trust in Allah.
3160. What is it?
Not 24434
I know what you're talking. I got the
message. 24434 means Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr,
Maghrib, and Isha. I got the hint.
What?
What is the number of that hotline? 3160
What is 3160?
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you, but if Allah forsakes you, who's
there then who will help you? So, let
the believers put their trust in Allah.
Correct?
So, you got the number of the hotline?
Don't forget it.
Hotline to Allah, direct.
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. If Allah forsakes you, who is there
that can help you?
So, let the believers put their trust in
Allah.
To gain confidence in public speaking
and conveying the beautiful message of
Islam, as well as dispute people's
misconception of Islam using Quran and
Sunnah as evidence.
Inshallah.
Number three, to take the experience and
knowledge in hopes
to move on to become a full-time day.
Inshallah.
How soon do you want to become full-time
day?
Brother Ibrahim.
After the course, Inshallah.
Inshallah.
May Allah make it possible and may Allah
fulfill your desire and ambition,
Inshallah.
Point number four, to be able to train
others in becoming a day.
Inshallah.
Number five, to be able to assess a
situation and have understanding of a
best route
route in inverted commas
of Dawah to give applicable to both
Muslims and non-Muslims.
Inshallah.
Expectation number six,
to learn
how to take control of a debate
and direct conversation
away irrational thinking
to rational thinking. To learn how to
take control of a debate and direct
conversation away irrational thinking to
rational thinking. We want to convert
the irrational way of thinking of people
to rational way, Inshallah. May Allah
Inshallah make it possible.
And this is where Allah says in the
Quran, the earlier verse quoted, Surah
Nahl, chapter number 16, verse number
125. Ud'u ila sabili rabbika bil hikmah
wal maw'izatil hasanah wajadilhum
billati ahsan. Invite all to the way of
thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preaching.
And argue with them and debate with them
in the ways that are best and most
gracious. Wajadilhum billati ahsan some
translate as reason with them.
Some have translated as argue, some have
translated as debate with them.
In the ways
that are best and most gracious.
And the last and the seventh expectation
is
to increase knowledge of ideologies of
other religions to understand the
motives.
Inshallah.
May Allah fulfill
all your expectations so that you come
closer to Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]